>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Now it's my pleasure
to introduce Sam Kean.
Sam is a science writer, as
I'm sure all of you know.
He's written several
very well-received books.
One is The Tale of
Dueling Neurosurgeons.
Another one is The
Disappearing Spoon.
They have been named among the
top science books on Amazon
in the years they came out.
He has been published by just about
everyone from the New York Times
to The Atlantic to Slate.
And his new book is called
Caesar's Last Breath.
And if you haven't read it,
it's much like his other books.
It makes science hugely readable.
And with no further ado, Sam Kean.
[ Applause ]
>> Sam Kean: All right.
Well, hello everyone.
Thank you all for joining
this evening.
So there's an old joke
about two fish
that are swimming along
in the ocean.
And they, you know, just
talking, hanging out,
and they pass by an old-timer fish.
And as they pass him
the old-timer fish says,
hey boys, how's the water today?
And the two fish just kind of
nod and keep going and then
about a minute later one of the
young fish turns to the other one
and he says, what the heck is water?
Now, that's not a very good joke, I
admit, but there is kind of a truth
in there, in that, you know, the
fish are so immersed in water
that they have a hard time
even realizing what water is.
And I think human beings are
in a lot the same relationship
with the air around us.
It's always around us, but it's
invisible, it's ubiquitous,
but we barely pay any
attention to it.
And so that's kind of the premise
of my book Caesar's Last Breath,
which is to make us pay attention to
the air, make us think about the air
in a way that we really
wouldn't otherwise.
And I think it's important
to be aware of the air,
because it is something we
really take for granted.
It might've been the first fact
you ever learned in science class,
which is that, you know, some things
are solid, some things are liquid,
and some things, like
air, are gases.
And we pay a lot of attention to the
solids and the liquids in our life,
but the gases are really the
most important thing around.
Because think about it, you
know, if you could go --
you know, if you had
to go without solids,
without food for a few
days, you'd probably live.
You'd pull through that.
Without liquids you
could go, you know,
maybe a week or so, you'd be okay.
But without gases, without the
air, you'd maybe last a few minutes
at most before you'd die.
Air is really the most important
thing in your environment right now,
and yet it's something we
barely pay attention to.
And so the premise of the
book was to know, you know,
imagine taking a deep
breath, inhaling,
exhaling all of these different
gases, things like nitrogen,
oxygen are the big ones,
but there's also things
like little bits of anesthesia.
There are noble gases.
There's ozone.
There are pollutants.
There are refrigerants.
There is radioactive fallout
from 1950's weapons testing
that is still in the air around us.
So the book examines the origins
of all of these gases and it tries
to tell kind of a funny or a spooky
or a touching story about each one
of them and how it shapes
our lives in hidden ways.
And there's actually something
kind of bigger connecting all
of these different gases, too,
kind of the overarching
story of the book.
And that is, if you look at these
different gases some of them come
from the very first
days of planet Earth.
They're billions of years old.
Some of these gases only came
about later with the rise of life.
about with the rise of
human civilizations.
So they're very new.
And if you look at all
of these gases in tandem,
kind of the whole ensemble of gases,
you can actually get a
complete history of Earth.
In fact, you can reconstruct
the whole history
of our planet every single time
you take a breath if you know how
to decode those stories
that are in those gases.
So I thought I would take a few
minutes tonight to try to share some
of the stories with you, and
just try to get you to be aware,
be more -- try to have
a better perspective
about what it is you're breathing.
So I'm going to start with
a very early planet Earth
and talk a little bit about
the early atmospheres on Earth.
And you sometimes hear that the
atmosphere is the most complicated
system that we know of
besides the human brain.
And it's true, the atmosphere is
a very, very complicated system.
And like a living thing the
atmosphere has evolved over time.
Our air has changed
throughout Earth's history.
So the very first atmosphere we had
was just some hydrogen and helium
that was left over from
the formation of the sun.
It was a very thin atmosphere,
very wispy atmosphere.
I call it sort of a comb over
atmosphere on our planet.
It wasn't very substantial.
It wasn't really fooling anyone.
And very quickly it got blown
away into space and disappeared.
But that was our first atmosphere,
was just made of this hydrogen
and helium left over from the sun.
Not long after that we
got our second atmosphere.
And the second atmosphere,
the air above us,
actually came from
the ground beneath us.
It came from volcanic
vents and fissures
and other things on the early Earth.
Early Earth was a very
dynamic place,
lots of volcanoes erupting
all the time.
They would spew out these hot, nasty
reactive gases that would then go up
and they started to build up
and form our first atmosphere.
You had things like hydrogen
sulfide, the rotten egg smell,
you had ammonia, and you especially
had carbon dioxide building up.
And if you were to get into a time
machine and go back to this era,
kind step out, you know, try to
stretch your arms a little bit
after your journey,
take a nice deep breath,
your lungs would just
start burning inside you.
This is very, very nasty
air to try to breathe.
It would have destroyed
your lungs basically.
So this was not the kind of air
that we wanted to, you know,
breathe that was really
supportive of life.
It was from volcanoes.
If you've ever been around a volcano
eruption, something like that,
you can imagine it's
not very pleasant gas.
But that was our second atmosphere,
was from these volcanoes,
the exhaust that would
come out volcanoes.
And so our third atmosphere
kind of took over gradually
from the second atmosphere.
What happened was, you
know, all these hot,
nasty gases would spew out,
but there was one component
of the eruptions that would kind
of sneak in there all the time,
and that component was nitrogen.
So nowadays, you know, nitrogen is
a dominant component of the air,
but with each one of these
eruptions you'd get a little tiny,
tiny bit of nitrogen, just is a very
small percentage that would sort
of seep out with each one
of these volcanic eruptions.
But what would happen is that
all these other hot nasty gases,
the carbon dioxide, the
sulfur dioxide, the ammonia,
they would go off and they
would start reacting with things
and eventually they would disappear,
they would fall out of the air.
But nitrogen is a very
unreactive gas, it's very hardy.
And once nitrogen gets into
the air it stays in the air,
and it stays in the air for a
really, really long time, millions,
sometimes even billions of years.
So when the nitrogen started leaking
out it would stay in the atmosphere.
But then, you know, you'd have
another volcanic eruption,
all these hot nasty gases would
come out, but they would react,
they would disappear, and you'd
get a little bit more nitrogen.
Then you'd have another eruption,
all the hot nasty gases would
come out, they would react,
they would disappear, you'd
get a little bit more nitrogen.
And it kept building up like this
very, very slowly over the years.
And when I say slowly, I
mean very, very slowly,
like the ultimate slow and steady.
It took a few billion years for
this process to happen for nitrogen
to finally build up to appreciable
levels in the atmosphere.
But after a few billion years
nitrogen became the dominant gas
in our atmosphere.
Now it makes up about
78% of our air,
so about four of every five
molecules we breathe came
from these volcanoes ultimately.
And we really should be thankful
for that because it allowed life
to form and exist on land.
If we still had all
that volcano exhaust
around there would be no way
we could support life on land
because the hot nasty air that
was around would just destroy it.
So we really should be thankful
for this volcano exhaust
and the little bit nitrogen
because it made life safe
for creatures like us on land.
So that was the third
atmosphere with nitrogen.
And eventually that gave rise
to the fourth atmosphere,
which is the one we have today.
And the fourth atmosphere,
the additional gas
that the fourth atmosphere
had in it was oxygen.
Oxygen is an important
gas, obviously for us.
And it's kind of weird
to think about the fact
that oxygen wasn't always a
part of Earth's atmosphere.
And, in fact, life arose on
Earth well before the first
oxygen existed.
And that's really strange
to think about,
because nowadays we associate
oxygen very, very closely with life.
It seems vital for life.
But in truth, oxygen was actually
toxic for most forms of life
that existed on early Earth.
Oxygen was actually a poison for
these creatures, microbes and things
that were around at the
time, and the reason why is
that oxygen is a very reactive gas.
Once oxygen started to get
inside these cells it would come
across these delicate biochemical
structures they had, enzymes,
other things, and chemically
oxygen is basically a big bully.
It goes in, it starts punching
things, ripping things apart,
destroying things,
and so these microbes
when they had oxygen inside them
it would basically destroy them.
It would rip everything
apart inside them.
So what these creatures, these
little microbes would do,
is they would actually expel oxygen.
They would get rid of it the way
that we get rid of carbon dioxide.
They would breathe it out and
let it go into the atmosphere.
And that worked fine
for them for a while.
But, unfortunately, enough of these
little critters started building
up where the oxygen level
started rising in the air.
And once they got to be an
appreciable level they started
to have some problems,
some big problems.
It would be like nowadays
if all of a sudden a bunch
of chlorine gas started
flooding the entire Earth,
you can imagine we would have
a lot of problems breathing
because it would sear
our lungs, it would start
to destroy the structures
inside of us.
It was doing the same thing to
these microbes, the oxygen was.
And eventually it built up to such
a high level that it started wiping
out huge swathes of these creatures.
And geologists can go back
and they can see evidence
of a mass extinction that
was caused by oxygen.
It was called the great
oxygen catastrophe.
So kind of this big, big event that
happened all because of this gas
that nowadays we associate
very, very closely with life.
But eventually though,
our ancestors,
these microbial ancestors,
did learn to harness oxygen.
They learned to tame it.
And what they did basically was
they started treating oxygen the way
that we treat plutonium
in a nuclear power plant.
So plutonium is a great
thing to have, you know,
a lot of energy it can give off,
but you have to keep a very
close eye on the plutonium.
You can't just have plutonium
sitting wherever you want inside one
of these power plants.
You have to keep it very tightly
confined to certain areas.
And ourselves eventually
learned to do this with oxygen.
They would harness it.
You kind of keep it -- keep it in
a confined area, but once they did
that they realized, wow, you know,
oxygen actually can
do a lot of things.
It's very reactive, very
energetic, and once you learn how
to harness oxygen that's when you
can get creatures that can do cool,
interesting things, creatures
that can run and jump
and think, creatures a lot like us.
So without this oxygen, you know,
we could have life on Earth,
but we definitely wouldn't
have the complex,
dynamic life that we have today.
Oxygen, this poison, is
really what enabled Earth
to support creatures like us.
And nowadays oxygen makes up
about 21% of our atmosphere,
so about one of every five molecules
we breathe is an oxygen molecule.
But that number has actually
kind of veered up and down a lot
over the history of the Earth, the
past few hundred million years.
At some times in Earth's history
it's dropped to as low as 15%.
And when oxygen is just at 15% fires
actually have a really hard time
starting out in nature.
Even things like lightning strikes
and volcano eruptions
really can't get fires going
when oxygen levels are that low.
And in fact, geologists, when they
look at the geological record,
they see no evidence of any
widespread fires anywhere
in Earth's history until just
a few hundred million years ago
when oxygen levels finally
built up high enough
where the atmosphere
could support burning.
So without oxygen we wouldn't
have fires around either.
So that was when oxygen
was at low levels,
but at other times it's
risen higher, much higher,
something to like 35%
of the atmosphere.
And when oxygen levels are at 35%
of the atmosphere you can
imagine that fires burn wildly.
You know, even dropping two
rocks, having a little spark
or something go off, all of a sudden
you had this huge conflagration
with fires burning everywhere.
So when oxygen levels
are that high it's kind
of a dangerous time to be alive.
It's also kind of a
creepy time to be alive,
because oxygen levels affect
the evolution of certain animals
in a kind of unusual way,
especially the evolution of insects.
So unlike us, insects
really don't have lungs.
So they don't -- you
know, we have lungs.
We breathe air in.
It dissolves the oxygen into
our blood and our blood takes it
around to our inner
cells, our inner organs.
Insects don't have lungs that work
quite the same way that we do.
Instead of having lungs
that inhale air,
what they have are
these little holes,
or little pores, on their skin.
And so the oxygen just kind of has
to passively diffuse
in through their skin.
And that works fine for them, it's
okay except, if the insects start
to get too big this passive process
of just letting oxygen flow in,
the insects actually struggle to get
oxygen to their deep interior cells.
And that's actually why
insects are always so tiny.
If you've ever wondered, you
know, like we have big birds,
we have big lizards,
we have big mammals,
why can't we have really
big insects?
Well, the answer why is that it's
because of their inefficient
breathing process.
They have a lot of
trouble getting oxygen
to their inner cells
if they get too large.
But if oxygen levels rise higher,
if they rise to say 35%, well,
all of a sudden you
can get very, very --
you can get very, very
large insects suddenly.
And they have seen
in the fossil record,
you can get millipedes
that are a yard long.
You can get dragonflies
the size of seagulls.
You can get spiders
the size of car tires.
Or who knows, you know, someday
we might even find bigger spiders
out there in the geological record.
We don't really know the limit
on how big these insects
could have gotten.
So we really should be thankful,
I think, for this nice even kind
of balance we have of oxygen at
about 21%, because we get things
like fires, we get the
warmth, all that stuff,
but we don't have a dog-sized creepy
crawlies running around either.
It is a nice balance that we have.
So in summary, that was
our four atmospheres.
And if you were paying attention
there you might've noticed
that I said, well, the
nitrogen makes up about 78%
of our atmosphere,
and the oxygen makes
up about 21% of our atmosphere.
And if you add those two together
that is already 99% of air.
And so you might be thinking,
well, you know, that other 1%,
it probably can't do
a whole lot, right?
Like it's just kind of 1%.
It's probably not that important.
Well, not so fast.
The analogy I like to make
is with a glass of wine.
So a glass of wine is
well over 99% oxygen --
or excuse me, water molecules
and alcohol molecules.
But if you think a glass of
wine is just water molecules
and alcohol molecules you're crazy.
There are the overtones of
wine, there's the finish,
all those other things in that
1% are what make the wine wine.
And it's really the
same way with our air.
That 1% is vitally important.
It gives the overtones
and the finish to our air.
For instance, all of global warming,
all of it, comes from that 1%.
All odors, all smells, all
scents, things like perfume,
barbecue sizzling,
fresh-baked bread,
all of that comes from that 1%.
We would be vastly poorer
without that 1% of our air.
And for the last story
tonight I'm going to look
at one of the gases in that 1%.
It's a gas you've probably
had in your home
at some point in your life.
It's one of the more important gases
in the history of civilization,
for better and often for worse.
So this story is a story
of rival inventors.
And these inventors were
working on home appliances.
And like most stories of rival
inventors, it's a story of winners,
and it's a story of losers.
And I'm going to get to
the winners in the moment,
but right now I'm going
to focus on the losers.
I'm going to especially focus on
the big, big loser in this story.
It's a man you might recognize,
kind of famous historically,
the big loser in this story.
So get ready to boo, get ready
to hiss, yeah, Albert Einstein.
Now, of course, we don't think about
Albert Einstein as a big loser,
and we definitely don't think about
him as a home appliances guru,
but in this story he
was actually both.
So one morning, 1926, Einstein
is reading the newspaper
when he almost choked on his eggs.
It turned out that an
entire family in Berlin,
including several children, had
died because of their refrigerator.
Refrigerators back then used
poisonous gases as coolants,
things like ammonia, methyl
chloride, sulfur dioxide and,
unfortunately, they often had spotty
motors with bad seals on them.
The seals would crack,
they would break,
these toxic gases would
leak out into the apartment.
And if it was tightly sealed enough
it would suffocate everyone inside.
And, unfortunately, this was
a kind of common occurrence.
And so Einstein called
up a scientist friend
of his named Leo Szilard.
You can se4e him in
the picture here.
And he had kind of this lump
in his throat and he said,
there must be a better way,
and it turned out there was.
So in the book I get into a little
bit more about the details here,
but just briefly this is
how a refrigerator works.
So imagine taking a
casserole, you know,
putting it in your
refrigerator to let it cool down.
If you were to tear
the inner panels off
of your fridge you would see a
series of tubes inside there.
These tubes have a
liquid inside them
that has a very low boiling point,
which means it turns
into a gas very easily.
And as your casserole starts
to give off heat the liquid
in the tubes absorbs the heat,
starts to boil, turns into a gas,
and that's good, because
having a gas gives you lots
of different options.
For one thing, gases are really,
really good at absorbing energy.
So they can suck up a lot
of heat from this casserole.
The other great thing about
gas is, is that they're mobile.
They can move very easily.
So after the liquid turns
into a gas it starts
to float away inside these tubes,
and eventually it winds its
way behind your refrigerator.
And if you've ever been behind
a refrigerator while it's
on you might've noticed that
it's a little warm back there
and get a little hot in the
back of your refrigerator.
What's happening is that the
gas that has taken the heat
from inside your fridge is
now dumping it out back.
The warmth is coming from
the gas dumping heat.
And that's basically the
art of refrigeration,
is the art of manipulating
gases to take heat
from one place inside the fridge,
move it to another place
outside the fridge.
So that's basically
how refrigerators work.
Now to work continuously in a
cycle and to keep things cold
over a long period, eventually the
fridge has to turn that gas back
into a liquid, and here's where
Einstein solved the problem.
One of the tricks that
refrigerators use to turn gases back
into liquids is they
use a compressor.
Basically it's just a piston
that squishes the gases down
and applies pressure to them.
If you've ever heard the hum, the
[humming sound], of refrigerators,
that's the compressor, that's
the motor running the compressor.
But, unfortunately,
as I said before,
motors back then had
bad seals on them.
They would crack.
All these gases would leak out.
They would kill people
in the apartment.
So what Einstein did,
and his friend Szilard,
they came up with some alternatives.
And actually they came up
with three different types
of alternative refrigerators.
The first one they came up with was
a very small scale refrigerator.
It still use a gas and
a liquid is a coolant,
but it was actually
powered by tap water.
So you would turn on
your kitchen sink
and it would power this
little tiny refrigerator.
Very innovative, very interesting.
Einstein thought it would
be for poor families,
ones who couldn't afford
a full refrigerator.
And it had this long king of
metal wand coming out of it.
And what you did is you took your,
you know, mug of water or beer
or whatever, and you took this wand
and you plunged it inside the mug
and it would cool things
down very quickly.
And again, Einstein thought this
would be great for poor people.
It would be very widespread
in Germany and Europe.
And so he came up with
a great name for it.
He called it [inaudible], which
means the people's fridge.
And I love that name,
the people's fridge.
So that was the first one,
was the people's fridge,
a very simple device.
The second refrigerator that he
and Szilard invented went the
complete opposite direction
in that it was a super
complicated, intricate device.
It had all these valves and
pumps and cooling lines in it.
There were these huge
electromagnetic coils in it.
It was pumping molten sodium
up and down during part of it.
As you can imagine, this
was a little bit impractical
of your average kitchen
in the 1920's,
to have these huge molten sodium
pumps kind of running around in it.
So it never really had any use as
an appliance, but in a few decades
after that it actually found use
in the nuclear power industry
where they would use it to
cool some nuclear power plant.
So even a few decades before
nuclear power existed, Einstein
and Szilard had invented
a way to cool the plant.
So that was kind of interesting.
But the third fridge, the third
fridge is the one they really
thought was going to be the big hit.
It had three different gases
inside it that it used as coolant.
So a very intricate system there.
And it was powered by
methane, by natural gas.
And the key part about
this refrigerator is
that it had no motor.
It didn't use any electricity.
So it was completely silent.
And because it had no motor
there was no weak spot.
There were no seals
to crack and break
and start leaking toxic gases
out into your apartment.
They could seal everything
up very tightly behind
thick sheets of metal.
So this refrigerator they invented
was suddenly very, very safe.
And now at this point you might
be thinking, I mean, come on,
this is Albert Einstein, like
the guy who invented relativity.
How much time was he
actually spending dinking
around on refrigerators?
And the answer is, well,
kind of a lot of time.
Again, he and Szilard invented three
different types of refrigerators.
And they filed for patents for them
in several different countries.
And as you can imagine, there
were a lot of patent lawyers
in these countries who
were a little surprised.
They would get the patent for, you
know, this new type of refrigerator.
They would start flipping through
it and then they would come
to the signature line and
they would say, wait a second,
Albert Einstein, that
Albert Einstein?
Well, you know, sure enough,
it was that Albert Einstein.
He had already revolutionized
our concept of space time,
why not revolutionize our
concept of home appliances?
It makes perfect sense.
And there was another reason
Einstein was very interested
in these refrigerators, kind of an
age old reason, and that was money.
Albert Einstein needed money.
He was living in Berlin
between the world wars
when inflation was
completely out of control.
At one point a loaf of bread,
just a single loaf of bread,
cost a billion Deutschmarks.
So inflation was out of
control, the economy was
in shambles, Einstein needed money.
He'd also sort of recklessly
divorced his first wife,
married another woman, he
had two families to support,
so he needed some cash
quick and he really thought
that these refrigerators were
going to be his meal ticket.
But there was just one problem,
those rivals that I
mentioned before.
Because it turns out, a few
chemists at General Motors
in Michigan were messing
around in the lab one day
when they invented a
new gas called Freon.
It turns out that Freon had a
very low boiling temperature,
so it could cool things
like casseroles very well.
It was completely --
it was very cheap
to make, so that's always good.
And it was completely non-toxic.
So refrigerator makers could keep
their old designs, they didn't have
to switch to this fancy
Einstein design,
they could keep their old
designs, swap in the Freon
and things would work just as well.
Because, you know, your motor might
break down, the Freon might leak
out in your apartment, but
it was completely non-toxic
so it didn't matter.
So no one ended up
using Einstein's design.
Nothing ever came of
it and it never ended
up in anyone's home unfortunately.
And this would have just been kind
of a curious footnote to the life
of Albert Einstein except for one
thing, that magical Freon gas,
as you can see here, the atoms
inside of it are chlorine atoms,
fluorine atoms, and carbon atoms.
It is a chlorofluorocarbon, a CFC.
And if there little hairs rising
on the back of your neck right now,
that is for a good reason.
Remember the hole in the
ozone layer, well CFC's,
chlorofluorocarbons like this,
were the ones that ate the
hole in the ozone layer.
People would take their
refrigerators, they would dump them
in junkyards, eventually
something would puncture the tank,
all these chlorofluorocarbons
would leak out,
they would go into the atmosphere,
and they would start gobbling
up all of the ozone there.
They are responsible for
the hole in the ozone layer.
And most people don't know it,
but chlorofluorocarbons are also
horrendous greenhouse gases.
Molecule by molecule they absorb
thousands of times more heat
than a molecule of
carbon dioxide does.
CFC's account for just parts per
billion of our atmosphere, so very,
very small parts per billion.
But they also account
for a full one quarter
of all human induced global warming.
So the world could have saved
itself a heck of a lot of trouble
in the long run if we had just gone
with Albert Einstein
and the people's fridge.
And that kind of brings
us full circle here,
because at the beginning of
the talk I was, you know,
mentioning volcanoes, how they
were spewing up these hot, nasty,
reactive gases into the atmosphere,
things like carbon dioxide, well,
nowadays we're putting carbon
dioxide and some other kind
of nasty gases back
into the atmosphere.
Our air has changed in the
past, and it's changing again.
The air is not the same air today
that our ancestors
breathed 250 years ago.
And it's probably not
going to be the same air
that our descendants breathe
250 years in the future.
We could be seeing the emergence
of a fifth distinct atmosphere.
Now, I spoke before about how
you can inhale the history
of the world every
time you take a breath.
Well, in a lot of ways that
history is still being written.
Early change was driven by
volcanoes, then later by microbes,
nowadays it's human beings.
We've inherited a big,
big responsibility,
and as a result the air is kind
of a controversial topic nowadays.
And again, we pay more attention to
solids and liquids than we do gases,
but I hope that people in
the future have the luxury
to take it air granted as well.
But the first step to preserving
air is understanding the air,
to notice the air, to notice
those little stories flitting
around in front you,
coursing into and out
of your lungs every
time you take a breath.
You have to make those
invisible stories visible,
the way your breath is visible
on a crisp November morning.
And I hope the talk tonight,
and I specially hope Caesar's
Last Breath can help you do that.
You know, pure air is odorless.
Pure air is colorless.
And by itself it sounds like
nothing, but that doesn't mean
that it's mute, that
it has no voice.
Air is actually burning to tell
its story if we just listen.
So again, thank you all
for coming out tonight.
I appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, yeah.
And I think we have time for
questions if anyone has some.
A little hard for me to
see, but okay, right there.
>> I was wondering where you
get your story ideas from.
>> Sam Kean: So she asked where
I get the story ideas from.
I pray every night for new
story ideas, I don't know.
They come out of nowhere.
With the books, especially though,
what I try to do is I want there
to be a central scientific topic.
You know, I wrote a book
about the periodic table,
about the human genome,
the brain, the atmosphere,
but I want to be able to branch
out into a lot of different things.
I don't want to just be
confined to sort of the science
or the lab work or
something like that.
So I want to make sure they are
really good stories out there,
and that's really what I focus on.
I'm looking for drama, conflict,
heroes, villains, things like that.
And beyond that, about, you know,
getting the details and things,
it's just a lot of reading, a lot
of hunting through footnotes and,
you know, reading as widely
as I can, reading fiction,
reading other genres, things I maybe
wouldn't think I'd be interested in,
just picking them up, reading them,
and seeing what pops into my head.
>> How did you get the
idea for this book?
>> Sam Kean: For this book,
a few different things.
I had heard a few stories about
the atmosphere, things I wanted
to get into, like the
Einstein refrigerator,
things about different gases.
And then just knowing air
is a controversial topic,
it's topical nowadays,
people are interested in it,
but we really do take
it for granted.
So that ability to kind of make
people appreciate, to see the air,
and then the stories in there
was an appealing combination.
Oh, we'll go there and then.
[ Inaudible ]
I heard -- if you can just
tell me I can repeat it.
[ Inaudible ]
So yeah, the atmosphere, it
depends on kind of where you want
to cut it off, because there are
different layers in the atmosphere.
So it depends on where
you want to cut it off.
[ Inaudible ]
Okay, so I'll take the second first.
That would be hard because
the atmosphere is much thicker
down here.
So it would be hard to like
get that turnover going.
And I think the pollution
would just kind
of eventually work its way down.
So I don't think that
would really work.
But you do make a good point,
that there are, you know,
some good things going on
in the atmosphere, too.
The air we breathe nowadays
is a lot cleaner in some ways
than the air we were breathing,
you know, 20, 30 years ago.
So we have done a very good
job of getting rid of a lot
of pollutants, things like that.
And the ozone layer has started
to come back in some cases.
In some areas it has shrunk.
We've provided that cover again.
So there are good stories out there
nowadays, a lot less acid rain
for instance, things like that.
But there are other things we're
still struggling with a lot, too.
So it's kind of improving in some
ways, not improving in others.
So there's hope out there.
[ Inaudible ]
Eliminating COC --
CFC's is one reason.
And then ozone builds
up naturally in the air.
So if you just give it time
eventually it will start
to form more.
>> Thank you.
>> Yes, thank you.
In your, sort of [inaudible]
account, shall we say,
you mentioned oxygen suddenly
appeared on the scene.
I never quite heard
where it came from,
but my understanding
is it came from plants.
>> Sam Kean: So oxygen when
it first started to appear
on the scene actually
came from microbes.
>> Right, right.
But the photosynthesis process.
>> Sam Kean: Photo --
it was photosynthesis.
>> Yeah, it's a type of plant.
>> Sam Kean: Yeah, yeah.
>> Where did they come from?
>> Sam Kean: Where did they come?
So the microbes were -- the
microbes appeared fairly early
in Earth's history,
and then eventually,
no one knows quite what happened,
they got the ability
to photosynthesize.
So it's just a long process
of, you know, incremental steps
where they finally built up
the chlorophyll molecules,
got the ability to photosynthesize,
and then they would expel
the oxygen as it a pollutant.
>> Thank you.
>> Sam Kean: Yeah.
>> With the pollution we got
with, you know, the fuel we use,
the fossil fuels, and then we
have all the animals and stuff,
it seems like a lot of people
are suppressing the information
that fossil fuels are causing a
bigger problem than the methane gas
that the animals produce.
What -- you know, the
greenhouse gas thing.
>> Sam Kean: Yeah, I mean, both
of them are contributing to it,
but fossil fuels and, you know,
vehicles and industrial production,
cement production actually produces
lots of -- lots of pollutants.
So there's lots of industry
things going into it, yeah.
>> But then what I'm saying is
that I think we need to concentrate
on the aspect of like the
animals and the methane like that,
you know what I'm saying?
>> Yeah, cows and other domesticated
animals do produce a lot of methane.
And there are people who
are trying to fix it.
You see -- like I saw these
pictures the other day of cows
with big backpacks on them
where it was trying to suck
up the methane that they produce.
You can imagine where
all the tubes went.
>> Yeah.
>> Sam Kean: There are people
working on this problem.
Or, you know, probably a
more realistic solution is
to add something to the feed that
can help break the methane down,
or to -- the methane is produced
actually by bacteria in their gut.
So if you could have
another bacteria
that could break the methane down,
there are scientists
working on the problem.
>> I was curious, how did
you come up with your title?
>> Sam Kean: Well, I
didn't come up with some
of the titles for the books.
With this one, I should actually
go to that slide if you like.
So actually it's kind
of a classic problem
for physics and chemistry students.
They ask them, what are the odds
that your breathing right now a
molecule the Julius Caesar breathed
during his last breath
when he got assassinated?
And your first thought might
be, well, that seems impossible.
There's no way any of Caesar's
last breath is still around.
I mean, he died over 2000 years ago
and anything he exhaled would
have just been like smeared
around the entire atmosphere.
Like the atmosphere is so
big compared to a breath
that the answer has to be zero.
It has to have disappeared by now.
But if you start to look
at it and like drill
down to the nitty gritty details,
it turns out that there are
so many molecules in every
breath we take, there are 25,
that's 25 sextillion molecules,
that's a 25 with 21 zeros after it.
There are so many molecules in
every breath we take that you start
to maybe think, well, you know,
that's a lot of molecules.
Like maybe some of
them are still around,
because most of them were nitrogen
molecules, which as I mentioned,
stick around for a
very, very long time.
So the question basically comes down
to, well, which is going to win,
that really big number or
the really small number
which is how big one breath is
compared to the overall atmosphere?
And it turns out that if you do
the math, go through all of it,
those two numbers cancel out almost
exactly, and it turns out that we --
every single time we take a breath
we inhale about one molecule
that Caesar did during his
last breath while he was
being assassinated.
So we have this direct
material connection to someone
like Julius Caesar every
single time we take a breath.
We are still inhaling
the same air that he did.
And, you know, it doesn't have
to be Julius Caesar either.
You can talk about Amelia
Earhart or Confucius
or Jumbo the giant circus elephant,
like any creature that ever lived
and breathed in the
history of planet Earth,
we are still inhaling the
same air that they did.
So air is one thing that really
unites all of human beings,
and it really connects us to our
past in a direct material way.
So that's why I chose it as
the title story for this book.
>> Thank you.
>> Sam Kean: Do we
have time for one more?
We'll do one more, all right.
>> I'm just wondering about
how the atmosphere is changing,
it's changing global warming,
but how does it affect us,
our evolution, changes
in [inaudible]?
>> Sam Kean: How does
it affect our evolution?
>> How would it?
>> Sam Kean: Okay, and
I should say, you know,
I'll be around for a
few minutes afterwards.
So if you are -- if you're too
shy, you have a burning question,
I'll be sticking around
for a little bit at least.
How it affects our evolution?
Well, it probably hasn't affected
our evolution too much yet,
but you can imagine it in the
future affecting our evolution
in some different ways.
You know, if pollutants start
to build up we are going to have
to become resistant
to those pollutants.
If the temperature increases
a lot we're going to have
to be more resistant to temperature.
If water become scarce we're
going to have to be better at,
you know, being dehydrated.
Things like that.
You do start to see evolution of
human beings in air with people
who live on mountain tops
in Tibet and other places.
They have a -- they have an
enhanced ability to breathe in --
or I should say, they have a
more efficient breathing process,
and they also have some
other biochemical changes
that you can see directly in their
genes because they've just had
to adapt to living
at higher elevations.
So if we have to escape
to the mountains someday
because it's too hot at sea level,
it could be another
adaptation we have.
So you probably will see
some changes in human beings
over the course of the next
few millennia, unfortunately.
But, again, I think that's it,
but thank you all for coming out.
I appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.